after his defeat Napoleon was exiled to
the small island of Elba here but why
there instead of literally anywhere else
on Earth well the reason why was mostly
the Russian Emperor Alexander the first
whose Army was one of the first into
Paris since Alexander just wanted to be
seen as a swell guy he negotiated with
the remainder of the French leadership
the Mediterranean was close enough to
keep an eye on Napoleon and so Alexander
chose one of the islands there Corsica
Sardinia and Sicily were too large to
give to Napoleon and so the tiny island
of Elba are now ruled by Austria was
chosen this was agreed by Russia Prussia
and Austria by the time the rest of the
Allies got to Paris which annoyed them
because Britain wanted to send Napoleon
to India as such it was simpler just to
agree with Russia than to rock the boat
over a defeated enemy and so off to Elba
Napoleon went